all right we're going to stop screwing
around because clearly we've just been
silly so far in the show
and that's not what the show's all about
we're going to get serious now we're
going to behave ourselves because folks
i think it's time once again
that we look into the future
the the future
conan that's right larry king let's all
look to the future all the way to the
year
[Applause]
is
mike tyson will prove he is still the
world's greatest boxer
when he takes a job assembling cardboard
boxes
parents will stop telling their kids
about the birds of the bees
when the birds and the bees release a
series of
bondage porno films
[Applause]
the beach boys will finally change their
names to the beach men
but only because michael jackson keeps
asking to meet them
[Applause]
[Music]
paris hilton's marriage will come to an
unfortunate
end after she decides that she wants to
see
600 other people
[Applause]
[Music]
sales of dr pepper will plummet after
it's revealed that dr pepper went to
medical school in guatemala
and he specializes in back alley boob
jobs
[Applause]
[Music]
hunters in alaska will shoot and kill a
black bear and then
discover to their horror that it was
actually a skinny dipping tony shalhoub
[Applause]
[Music]
scientists will discover that galapagos
turtles live for a long time
not because of their slow metabolism but
because they just want to be a burden
on their children
[Music]
not having a joke to tell of his own
larry king will take a phone call
wichita falls you're on the air hello
larry long time listener first time
caller
great uh what's your prediction angelina
jolie
will break up yet another happy marriage
when she gets between star
jones and her waffles
[Applause]
[Music]
larry king will lose his endorsement
deal with welch's grape juice
when it's revealed king hasn't had juice
in his grapes for over 20 years
[Applause]
[Music]
i larry king will call conan o'brien and
ask him to appear on my show as
man of the year o'brien will arrive at
the designated time
only to find an empty studio i will be
sitting at home
laughing my
larry king ladies and gentlemen he
nailed it that was great
you